how're you doing man I like what you got
here you got a champ you got water and a
champagne flute so it's like very fake
classy this is the kind of [ __ ] I do
where well I should not a grab your
water before I looked at you you are
[ __ ] huge
oh my god dude holy [ __ ] hey man there
you go
take my hand boss you our offensive
lineman Bakke what do you do for a
living you got a nice suit like you make
money clearly but what do you do
[Applause]
who the [ __ ] all that gonna I expected
it not from you I know Indians well
enough to know you guys might not work
IT you two could definitely work IT I
know what India is from when an Indian
is from India these two [ __ ]
boy my man got on like a Umbro shirt or
like [ __ ] locked or one of those come
companies you don't give a [ __ ] about in
the u.s. playing soccer dogs you in a
soccer polo who's doing that that's a
[ __ ] Indian man I know a Indian
drinking diet coke and the [ __ ]
sangria glass this is a this is this is
an Indian that's IT in dealer
I did not expect IT from the [ __ ]
offensive linemen how much you notice
not cuz your black is cuz you're
enormous you look like three regular IT
dudes holy [ __ ]
those two together still not your
shoulders isn't that [ __ ] crazy look
at these two guys right here you put
their shoulders together do you think it
really matches his [ __ ] shoulders
what suit size are you three just three
suits just grab three jackets cut off
one sleeve put them together as is what
we gotta do we gotta make this [ __ ] work
they're all a poncho on them cut some
holes where you can't figure it out oh
my god dude you are huge I just grab
your water disrespected you then looked
up and I was like whoa did not think
that through oh my goodness
all right so you work an IT well it's
obvious how you found out about me
guys got co-workers I assume you know
was it you guys what's going on how's
India doing in cricket I need to know I
know you know I'm surprised you didn't
come here in [ __ ] sandals [ __ ] get
the good bottom we're going baka is
somehow they sandal that everybody every
Indian has bought da sandals I swear to
God you have an Indian friend I assume
it's its Jersey all you do you go look
in a closet you'll see at least three
baka sandals and those are like we're
going to the Munder we got to go pray
but we take our shoes off before we go
so I got a flex on them a little bit and
I mean I'm gonna be barefoot inside
flexing outside I teach people no I'm
not [ __ ] poor I got locked out money
[Music]